Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. They seek him here, they seek him there, his clothes allowed, but never square. It will make or break him, so he's got to buy the best, because he's a dedicated follower of fashion. And when he does his little rounds around the boutiques of London town, eagerly pursuing all the latest fads and trends because he's a dedicated follower of fashion. That, Dominic, was The Kinks, dedicated follower of fashion, which I think came out in 1966. And it is a kind of mocking commentary on the status of London, the very unexpected status of London in the mid-60s, as the world capital of fashion, which is today's subject, right? It is.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。他们在这里找他，在那里找他，他的衣服很时髦，但从不循规蹈矩。这会成就他，也会毁了他，所以他必须买最好的，因为他是时尚的忠实追随者。当他在伦敦城的精品店里转悠，热切地追求所有最新的时尚和潮流时，因为他是时尚的忠实追随者。多米尼克，那是奇想乐队（The Kinks）的《时尚的忠实追随者》，我想是1966年发行的。这是一种对伦敦地位的嘲讽式评论，60年代中期伦敦作为世界时尚之都的地位非常出人意料，这正是今天的主题，对吧？没错。
So you and I were talking about this just before we started recording, weren't we, Tom? We're having a dispute, a historical dispute about fashion history. Because I said, I think this is the one moment when Britain can genuinely claim to be the world capital of fashion, when British fashion is genuinely setting the trend worldwide. And you said, no, there was an earlier one. Yes, because I think you had forgotten the brilliant episode we did with Hilary Davidson on fashion in the age of Jane Austen, where she talked about how during the Napoleonic Wars, Britain is cut off from Paris, which is traditionally the growth of shopping in London and other cities, Bath and so on, for the first time, you get the idea of fashion as something that is kind of changing season upon season. And so very, very fleetingly in that period, the Regency period, kind of late, very late 18th century and into the first years of the 19th century, London then is perhaps the
所以，汤姆，我们在录音前刚聊到这个，对吧？我们正在进行一场争论，一场关于时尚史的历史性争论。因为我说，我认为这是英国唯一能真正宣称自己是世界时尚之都的时刻，当时英国时尚确实在引领全球潮流。而你说，不，之前还有一次。是的，因为我想你忘了我们和希拉里·戴维森（Hilary Davidson）一起做的关于简·奥斯汀时代时尚的精彩节目，她在节目中谈到拿破仑战争期间，英国如何与巴黎隔绝，而巴黎传统上是伦敦和其他城市（如巴斯等）购物增长的源头，你第一次有了时尚随季节更替的概念。所以在那段时期，即摄政时期，18世纪末到19世纪初的最初几年，伦敦或许是
capital of fashion. I mean, it doesn't last, but I take your point that the thing that's fascinating about London in the 60s is that it is not just for elites as it was back in the Regency period, but basically for everyone. I mean, that's the selling point, isn't it? That's how it's seen. The whole of London is full of people in miniskirts. Which is obviously not really true, as we will discover, but there is a sort of an overtly democratic ethos to 60s fashion, isn't there? There's a democratic ethos, there is a sense of mass consumerism. The funny thing about a podcast about 60s fashion, there may be lots of people listening who think, well, I'm not very interested in fashion. But fashion in the 60s becomes, I think, a kind of metaphor, a symbol of wider social changes.
时尚之都。我的意思是，它并没有持续下去，但我明白你的观点，60年代伦敦最迷人的地方在于，它不仅仅像摄政时期那样只为精英服务，而是基本上为所有人服务。我的意思是，这就是卖点，不是吗？这就是人们眼中的伦敦。整个伦敦到处都是穿着迷你裙的人。这显然不是真的，正如我们将要发现的那样，但60年代的时尚有一种公开的民主精神，不是吗？有一种民主精神，有一种大众消费主义的感觉。关于60年代时尚的播客有趣的地方在于，可能有很多听众会想，嗯，我对时尚不太感兴趣。但60年代的时尚，我认为，已经成为一种隐喻，一种更广泛社会变革的象征。
So the rise of the teenage, or the rise of the teenage at the rise of youth culture but also the enormous economic recovery from the austerity of the 1940s and the privations of world war ii yeah and the development of this sort of new this what they call in france the 30 glorious years of full employment and economic growth and consumerism and urbanization and all these kinds of things and fashion actually stands in i I think, for a lot of that. Well, that was what is so interesting about the 60s that I now appreciate over and over again is that it only really makes sense in the context of the privations of the Second World War.
所以青少年的兴起，或者说青年文化的兴起，还有从40年代的紧缩政策和二战的匮乏中巨大的经济复苏，是的，以及这种新事物的发展，法国人称之为“光辉三十年”的充分就业、经济增长、消费主义、城市化以及所有这些事情，而时尚实际上代表了其中的很多内容。嗯，这就是60年代最有趣的地方，我现在一遍又一遍地意识到，它只有在第二次世界大战匮乏的背景下才有意义。
Yeah. That the kind of the blaze of color that you associate with the 60s exists in the kind of the monochrome context of the austerity that was the accompaniment of the war years. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. As we'll see with this story, it only makes sense when you go back 20 years and to see what people are, as you say, reacting against. So what people's parents had grown up wearing actually. Yeah. So people will have an Austin Powers type, groovy baby kind of, you know, guys wearing incredibly frilly shirts.
是的。你与60年代联系在一起的那种色彩斑斓，存在于战争年代伴随的紧缩政策那种单调的背景中。是的，我认为这绝对正确。正如我们将在这个故事中看到的，只有当你回溯20年，看看人们正如你所说的那样在反抗什么，它才有意义。也就是人们的父母成长过程中穿的东西。是的。所以人们会有奥斯汀·鲍尔斯（Austin Powers）那种“时髦宝贝”的感觉，你知道，男人们穿着极其褶皱的衬衫。
What is it in the kinks of the verse I didn't read about skin tight, frilly panties being drawn up tight, all that kind of stuff. And girls in kind of plastic max and mini skirts and high boots and all that kind of thing. So put that against the kind of the image that we have of the war years. I guess it's a little bit unfair because we tend to think of the war years in black and white, don't we? Because the footage is black and white. But there is a kind of slightly monochrome quality to the fashion. Oh, there is. Absolutely. If you look at some photos of people in the 1930s and 1940s, just because of the availability of dye, actually, Tom, because the industrial processes for making clothes, I mean, it's expensive.
奇想乐队歌词里提到的紧身褶皱内裤被拉得很紧，诸如此类。还有穿着塑料雨衣、迷你裙和高筒靴的女孩等等。所以把这些与我们对战争年代的印象相对比。我想这有点不公平，因为我们倾向于认为战争年代是黑白的，不是吗？因为影像资料是黑白的。但时尚确实有一种轻微的单调感。哦，确实。绝对是。如果你看一些30年代和40年代人的照片，仅仅是因为染料的可用性，汤姆，因为制造衣服的工业流程，我的意思是，这很昂贵。
It's expensive to wear colored clothes. But also, of course, most people are a huge proportion of people. Let's just think about Britain specifically. But this is actually true of the United States, France, wherever. Lots of people work in factories, in coal mines, in very dirty jobs, in a very smoky environment. Houses heated by coal fires or whatever. So it actually doesn't make sense to wear very brightly colored, delicate clothes. You want to actually wear very hard wearing and dark clothes that will take the dirt effectively. Also, a massively
穿彩色衣服很贵。但当然，大多数人，很大一部分人。让我们专门想想英国。但这实际上也适用于美国、法国，无论哪里。很多人在工厂、煤矿工作，在非常肮脏的工作中，在烟雾缭绕的环境中。房子由煤火取暖等等。所以穿颜色非常鲜艳、精致的衣服实际上没有意义。你实际上想穿非常耐穿和深色的衣服，能有效地防脏。此外，一个被严重
underappreciated point, you are colder. You're living in a world without central heating. So you wear more layers. You wear your coat much more often, you might obviously wear a hat if you're a man, and you have fewer items of clothing. So let's say the outbreak of the Second World War, a middle-class woman in Britain would probably have about seven or eight dresses, a couple of suits, three coats, six pairs of shoes or something. A working-class woman, of which there are many, of course, they might have a far smaller wardrobe, three dresses, a couple of pairs of shoes. A man would generally have suits, an overcoat. Now, an overcoat, something like that would probably cost the equivalent in the dent in your budget of about a thousand pounds in today's money. That's a lot of money.
低估的观点是，你更冷。你生活在一个没有中央供暖的世界里。所以你穿更多的层数。你更频繁地穿外套，如果你是男人，你显然可能会戴帽子，而且你的衣服件数更少。所以假设在第二次世界大战爆发时，英国的一位中产阶级女性大概会有七八件连衣裙、几套西装、三件外套、六双鞋之类的。而工人阶级女性，当然有很多，她们的衣橱可能小得多，三件连衣裙，几双鞋。男人通常会有西装、大衣。现在，一件大衣，那样的东西在当时的预算中可能相当于今天的一千英镑。那是一大笔钱。
That's a lot of money. So the coat that you would buy, I mean, that might last you for 20, 30 years. You might actually pass it on to your son or to a family member. Oh, and imagine if you leave it in the pub. Well, that's a bit, I mean, that's the kind of thing that comes up in films, in novels, people will leave their coats behind or their hats or something.
那是一大笔钱。所以你买的外套，我的意思是，那可能会穿20、30年。你实际上可能会把它传给你的儿子或家庭成员。哦，想象一下如果你把它落在酒吧里。嗯，那有点，我的意思是，那是电影、小说里会出现的事情，人们会把外套或帽子之类的东西落在后面。
Run back and run into the lady. Exactly, it's a big deal. And they're heavy, they're heavy fabrics, they're dark. So yes, there is a sort of, what you described as the monochrome world. Of course, it is distorted in that popular imagination because of cinematography. But it's not entirely inaccurate. And then, of course, the war comes.
跑回去撞到女士。没错，这可是件大事。而且它们是厚重的面料，颜色深。所以是的，有一种你所描述的单调世界。当然，由于电影摄影，它在流行想象中被扭曲了。但它并非完全不准确。然后，当然，战争来了。
So in Britain, clothing is rationed between 1941 and 1949. So you get 66 clothing coupons a year at first, and then that is actually steadily cut as the war goes on. How long does that last, the clothing ration? Because isn't that the Queen's wedding dress? Yes. There's all kinds of problems with how many coupons she has. Exactly. That's exactly right. So it actually lasts until 1949, so four years after the Second World War. And the moment that, if we have any listeners who are old enough to remember the war, that they would remember is in 1942, the Board of Trade brings in a new thing where you have to have what's called utility clothes. And they limit
所以在英国，1941年到1949年间实行服装配给。所以你起初每年有66张服装券，然后随着战争的进行，这实际上在稳步削减。服装配给持续了多久？因为那不是女王的婚纱吗？是的。她有多少张券有很多问题。没错。完全正确。所以它实际上一直持续到1949年，也就是第二次世界大战结束四年后。如果我们的听众中有足够大年纪记得战争的人，他们会记得在1942年，贸易委员会引入了一项新规定，你必须拥有所谓的“实用服装”。他们限制了
the number of fabrics that are available to you, but they also limit the number of designs. And there are all kinds of restrictions. So to give you some examples that may sound absolutely bizarre to people now, men's shirts are not allowed to have double cuffs. So in other words, cufflinks. You can't have kind of puffy sleeves on a shirt, on a women's shirt. Men are not allowed to have, from that point onwards, people are not making double-breasted suits because it's a waste of cloth. Turnips on your trousers.
你可以使用的面料数量，但他们也限制了设计数量。而且有各种各样的限制。所以举几个对现在的人来说可能听起来绝对离奇的例子，男士衬衫不允许有双袖口。换句话说，袖扣。你不能在女式衬衫上有那种蓬松的袖子。从那时起，男士不允许有双排扣西装，因为那是浪费布料。裤子上的翻边。
So trousers don't have turnips anymore i think that's probably probably a good thing well it depends on the look you want i'm not a turn up on a trouser man tommy i'm not i think that's a kind of positive from the wall you're limited to uh three buttons per garment so you know i mean if you want a shirt or something with loads of buttons you're not going to get it. And most famously, you're only allowed to use elastic on women's knickers, on nothing else. Even the length of a man's sock is limited to nine inches. And people actually complain. Some people complain.
所以裤子不再有翻边了，我想这可能是一件好事。嗯，这取决于你想要的造型。汤姆，我不是那种喜欢裤子翻边的人。我认为那是战争带来的积极影响。你每件衣服仅限使用三个纽扣，所以你知道，我的意思是，如果你想要一件有很多纽扣的衬衫之类的，你是得不到的。最著名的是，你只允许在女式内裤上使用松紧带，其他地方都不行。甚至男士袜子的长度也被限制在9英寸。人们实际上抱怨。有些人抱怨。
They say, well, I wanted longer socks. What about schoolboys? That's a very good question. I would say schoolboys probably... They got away with it because their legs are shorter. If you're a very small schoolboy, yes. I was a very short schoolboy, so I would have been laughing. But that continues after the war.
他们说，嗯，我想要更长的袜子。那男学生呢？这是一个很好的问题。我会说男学生可能……他们逃过一劫，因为他们的腿更短。如果你是一个非常小的男学生，是的。我是一个非常矮的男学生，所以我当时会笑。但这在战后还在继续。
So in the late 1940s, because there's not much leather, the shoe industry is kind of restricted. The government had adopted a slogan in 1943, make, do, and mend, which you and I will, I mean, we grew up with people talking about make do and mend, didn't we? I mean, it's actually entered the, certainly in Britain, it's entered the English language as a, we don't think of it as having a kind of wartime sort of ethos. And that's not lifted until 1949. So the kind of clothes that people were wearing, just last note on the war, they're very boxy, kind of utilitarian. There's obviously a kind of militaristic vogue. There's a status, I suppose, in a funny way, in wearing very sort of boxy, utilitarian clothes. And these are the demob suits that discharged soldiers get at the end of the war.
所以在40年代末，因为皮革不多，鞋业受到了一定限制。政府在1943年采用了“凑合、将就、修补”（make, do, and mend）的口号，你和我，我的意思是，我们是在人们谈论“凑合、将就、修补”的环境中长大的，不是吗？我的意思是，它实际上已经进入了，当然在英国，它已经进入了英语语言，我们并不认为它有一种战时的精神。直到1949年才取消。所以人们穿的那种衣服，关于战争的最后一点，它们非常方正，实用主义。显然有一种军国主义的时尚。以一种有趣的方式，穿非常方正、实用的衣服有一种地位感。这些就是退伍军人在战争结束时得到的退伍西装。
Yeah, and they're cheap suits. You're a young man, that's the only suit you own. And people complain about the demob suits. Obviously, they say their arm comes off and it's rubbish and it doesn't look good and all this sort of stuff but at the same time something quite democratic about it because everyone's wearing the same suit is there a sense still of le steel anglais the uh the look of the english gentleman is that still a thing fine tailoring and saville row and well that's at the very top end i think generally english clothes are very conservative actually, in the 1940s.
是的，它们是廉价西装。你是一个年轻人，那是你拥有的唯一一套西装。人们抱怨退伍西装。显然，他们说袖子会掉下来，质量很差，看起来不好看等等，但与此同时，它有一种相当民主的感觉，因为每个人都穿着同样的西装。是否仍然有一种“英国绅士风度”（le style anglais），英国绅士的造型，那还是个东西吗？高级定制和萨维尔街，嗯，那是在最高端，我认为总的来说，英国服装在40年代实际上非常保守。
The image of English fashion abroad certainly is very conservative. I don't think people in France, Italy, the traditional powerhouses of fashion, they're not looking to London and saying, gosh, is London going to lead the way after the war? Nobody would ever- Okay. And so Paris has been under German occupation. Yes. But in the wake of the war, famously, it's the phoenix from the ashes.
英国时尚在国外的形象确实非常保守。我不认为法国、意大利这些传统的时尚强国的人们会看着伦敦说，天哪，伦敦战后会引领潮流吗？没人会……好吧。所以巴黎一直处于德国占领之下。是的。但在战后，众所周知，它是浴火重生的凤凰。
It's the butterfly re-emerging and taking wing, isn't it, with the new look? It is, absolutely. So this is a guy called Christian Dior, who is very glamorously, Tom, he's the son of a fertilizer manufacturer from Normandy. And he makes uniforms for German officers in the war, doesn't he? Notoriously. Well, German officers' wives. Ah, okay. I'm being unfair on him then. So actually what happens is Dior wanted to be an artist and he ended up sketching for a fashion house and then he ends up designing the clothes. And yes, in the war during the occupation,
它是重新破茧成蝶并展翅高飞，不是吗，带着“新风貌”（New Look）？是的，绝对是。所以这是一个叫克里斯蒂安·迪奥（Christian Dior）的人，他非常迷人，汤姆，他是诺曼底一家化肥制造商的儿子。他在战争期间为德国军官制作制服，不是吗？臭名昭著。嗯，德国军官的妻子们。啊，好吧。那我对他不公平了。所以实际上发生的是，迪奥想成为一名艺术家，他最终为一家时装屋画草图，然后他最终设计了这些衣服。是的，在战争期间，在占领期间，
he does design clothes or he's said to have designed clothes for the wives of German officers. I mean, to be fair, I don't think this is some sign of some latent Nazism in Christian Dior. I mean, he's living under the occupation. He has no choice, effectively. I mean, lots of people are, I don't know, baking croissants for German officers or whatever. Fair enough. But then there is this absolute landmark moment, which all fashion historians and anybody interested in the history of clothes will know, which is the 12th of February 1947, when he unveils his first individual collection. This is the birth of what's called the new look. Everything that we described, the very austere, utilitarian look of clothes, Dior ditches all that. His clothes, they their women's clothes, they are very glamorous,
他确实设计了衣服，或者说据说是为德国军官的妻子们设计了衣服。我的意思是，公平地说，我不认为这是克里斯蒂安·迪奥身上某种潜在纳粹主义的迹象。我的意思是，他生活在占领之下。他实际上别无选择。我的意思是，很多人都在，我不知道，为德国军官烤羊角面包之类的。有道理。但随后出现了这个绝对的里程碑时刻，所有时尚历史学家和任何对服装历史感兴趣的人都会知道，那就是1947年2月12日，他发布了他的第一个个人系列。这就是所谓的“新风貌”的诞生。我们所描述的一切，那种非常朴素、实用的服装，迪奥抛弃了所有这些。他的衣服，它们是女装，它们非常迷人，
narrow waist and then great sweeping kind of skirts and dresses, emphasizing sort of voluptuousness and sexuality and curves and lush. They're really kind of lush, glamorous clothes. And of course, against the backdrop of a Europe that is, I mean, every country in Europe is full of bombed out buildings, homeless people, poverty stricken. There's a sense of escapism to the New York. And presumably it has to be Paris where this happens. No other city would have this impact because Paris has this legacy as the great center of fashion. Yeah. And this is evidence that Paris is back after the humiliations and sufferings of the war.
窄腰，然后是巨大的扫地式裙子和连衣裙，强调那种丰满、性感、曲线和华丽。它们确实是那种华丽、迷人的衣服。当然，在欧洲的背景下，我的意思是，欧洲的每个国家都充满了被炸毁的建筑物、无家可归的人、贫困潦倒。新风貌有一种逃避现实的感觉。大概它必须在巴黎发生。没有其他城市会有这种影响，因为巴黎拥有作为伟大时尚中心的遗产。是的。这证明了巴黎在战争的屈辱和苦难之后回来了。
Yes. So it's interesting that the phrase, the new look, is coined by an American journalist who is watching the unveiling of Dior's show. And she says, oh, Christiane, what a new look you've adopted. But the very fact that there are journalists there to watch it tells you that it's the focus of attention it's the focus of the world's attention and you know the clothes are reproduced in english magazines and english newspapers indeed in american magazines and newspapers that wouldn't be the case if they were being unveiled and you know it pains me to say it tom but if they're being unveiled in birmingham yeah that would not
是的。所以有趣的是，“新风貌”这个词是由一位观看迪奥时装秀揭幕的美国记者创造的。她说，哦，克里斯蒂安，你采用了多么新的风貌啊。但有记者在那里观看这一事实本身就告诉你，它是关注的焦点，它是世界关注的焦点，你知道，这些衣服在英国杂志和英国报纸上被转载，实际上在美国杂志和报纸上也是如此，如果它们是在，你知道，这让我很痛苦，汤姆，如果它们是在伯明翰揭幕的，那将不会
be the uh the world would not be watching fair Fair enough. So it's sort of an illusion, actually, the new look, because most people can't afford new look clothes. They are still living in this sort of world. I mean, rationing is still going for another two years in Britain, but it's an aspiration. And does this percolate through
是……世界不会关注。有道理。所以这实际上是一种幻觉，新风貌，因为大多数人买不起新风貌的衣服。他们仍然生活在这种世界里。我的意思是，英国的配给制还在持续两年，但它是一种渴望。这是否渗透到
into kind of mass market clothing in Britain? Slowly. In the long run? Yes, in the long run. Exactly. In the 1950s. So actually what happens is after 1949, when the Russians are lifted, the British economy takes another two or three years to really sort of fire up again.
英国的大众市场服装中？缓慢地。从长远来看？是的，从长远来看。没错。在50年代。所以实际上发生的是，1949年配给取消后，英国经济又花了二三年时间才真正重新启动。
And when it does fire up again, obviously people are buying different clothes. They're buying more lightweight clothes, more colorful. They're keen to sort of put the wartime experience and the heaviness behind them. That said, when you look at pictures of the early to mid-1950s, and young people, I mean, if you look at some of the famous young people in Britain of the early to mid-50s, so Kingsley Amis, Philip Larkin, the writers who come of age in that period or people like that, they're wearing tweed suits, heavy shoes, a tie often, an overcoat. They are wearing versions of the sort of heavy clothes that their parents would have worn. So kind of intellectual young men who like jazz are still wearing suits, right?
当它重新启动时，人们显然在买不同的衣服。他们买更轻便、更鲜艳的衣服。他们渴望把战时的经历和沉重感抛在脑后。话虽如此，当你看看50年代初到中期的照片，以及年轻人，我的意思是，如果你看看50年代初到中期英国一些著名的年轻人，比如金斯利·艾米斯（Kingsley Amis）、菲利普·拉金（Philip Larkin），那些在那个时期成年的作家或类似的人，他们穿着粗花呢西装、厚重的鞋子、通常打着领带、穿着大衣。他们穿着他们父母会穿的那种厚重衣服的版本。所以喜欢爵士乐的知识分子年轻人仍然穿着西装，对吧？
They are. Absolutely, they are. Absolutely, they are. But we've talked about the influence of Paris. What about the influence of America? Because American troops have been over in Britain, and there's a kind of a sense that America is vibrant, colorful, wealthy, relaxed. Everything that bombed out, stuffy Britain isn't. Is that having an impact on fashion? Hollywood always has an impact on fashion. So even in the 1930s, I say even in the 1930s,
他们是。绝对是，他们是。绝对是，他们是。但我们谈到了巴黎的影响。那美国的影响呢？因为美国军队一直在英国，有一种感觉，美国是充满活力、色彩鲜艳、富有、放松的。所有被炸毁、沉闷的英国所不是的一切。这是否对时尚产生了影响？好莱坞总是对时尚有影响。所以即使在30年代，我说即使在30年代，
especially in the 1930s, people are often complaining, sort of Daily Express columnists are complaining that young women in Britain are copying American fashions. But actually, the fashions they're copying are not so different from what they're wearing themselves. They might be a particular cut of a skirt or something like that but they're not people aren't all dressing in jeans or anything like that what you do have is people who are copying for example biker films in the mid-1950s so that's the leather jackets so that's the sort of ancestors of the rockers we'll come to the modern rockers in a second and you do have a group of people now who are different who have not really existed except in embryonic form in the 30s before.
特别是在30年代，人们经常抱怨，某种《每日快报》的专栏作家抱怨英国年轻女性在模仿美国时尚。但实际上，她们模仿的时尚与她们自己穿的并没有太大不同。它们可能只是裙子的特定剪裁之类的，但它们不是……人们并没有都穿着牛仔裤之类的。你确实有模仿，例如50年代中期摩托车电影的人，所以那是皮夹克，所以那是摇滚客（rockers）的祖先，我们一会儿会谈到现代摇滚客，你确实有一群人现在不同了，除了30年代之前的胚胎形式外，并没有真正存在过。
And that, of course, is teenagers. Right. So teenagers have money. So much of this story is about young women. But actually, the first example of a sort of fashion subculture in the 50s is the Teddy Boys. And Teddy Boy, the Teddy, is Edward VII, right? Yes. The Edwardian period.
那当然就是青少年。没错。所以青少年有钱。这个故事的很大一部分是关于年轻女性的。但实际上，50年代某种时尚亚文化的第一个例子是泰迪男孩（Teddy Boys）。泰迪，泰迪是爱德华七世，对吧？是的。爱德华时期。
I mean, that's the weird thing. It is. The new look also is kind of very influenced by the sweep and the color and the cut of Edwardian dress. It is, because actually if you think about what was very cool in, let's say, the 20s, it was a very androgynous look for women, for example. Let's say flappers, most famously. So the new look is actually looking back to the much more romantic, glamorous fashions of the Edwardian period. Do you think that's because there's a sense that it's not just the Second World
我的意思是，那很奇怪。确实。新风貌也受到爱德华时期服装的风格、颜色和剪裁的很大影响。确实，因为实际上如果你想想在，比如说，20年代什么很酷，那对女性来说是一种非常中性的造型，例如。比如说飞来波女郎（flappers），最著名的是。所以新风貌实际上是在回顾爱德华时期更浪漫、更迷人的时尚。你认为这是因为有一种感觉，不仅仅是第二次世界
War, but the First World War? There's been this continuous process of conflict and convulsion. Yeah, of course. Therefore, perhaps the Edwardian period is seen as something to get back to. Yeah, it's where you would look to. It's where you would look to, because people aren't going to look back to the 1920s Flapper fashions because they're- Yeah, you know something to get back to yeah i would i mean it's the it's where you would look to it's where you would look to because people aren't going to look back to the 1920s flapper fashions because they're yeah you know what's coming yeah yeah that's the day before yesterday but yeah so with the with the teddy boys edwardian as you said um that again it's it's not i mean it's so different from the new look but actually it's not dissimilar in the sense that it's an attempt
大战，还有第一次世界大战？一直有这种持续的冲突和动荡过程。是的，当然。因此，也许爱德华时期被视为可以回归的东西。是的，那是你会看的地方。那是你会看的地方，因为人们不会回顾1920年代的飞来波女郎时尚，因为它们……是的，你知道有什么要来了，是的，那是前天的事，但是的，所以对于泰迪男孩，爱德华风格，正如你所说，嗯，那再次，它不是……我的意思是，它与新风貌非常不同，但实际上它并不相似，因为它是一种尝试
to inject a kind of romanticism and a glamour to clothing. But that is bottom up, right? No, not initially. This is interesting. So people do think the Teddy Boys are bottom up. But actually, what seems to have happened, and of course, when you're writing about fashion history, you're actually just picking up fragments of stuff and trying to get some sense of a narrative out of it. What are people wearing here? What are people wearing here? What are people wearing there? There's some suggestion that actually rich, upper middle class young men at the end of the 1940s,
给服装注入一种浪漫主义和魅力。但那是自下而上的，对吧？不，最初不是。这很有趣。所以人们确实认为泰迪男孩是自下而上的。但实际上，似乎发生的事情是，当然，当你写时尚史时，你实际上只是在拾取一些碎片，试图从中得到某种叙事感。人们在这里穿什么？人们在这里穿什么？人们在那里穿什么？有一些暗示，实际上40年代末富有的上中产阶级年轻人，
as rationing is coming to an end, as there's a little bit more money around, are making a little bit of effort to just look a bit fancier. So a fancy collar or a nice waistcoat or narrower trousers and stuff. And then basically what seems to have happened is that percolated down. Let's say you're 21 and you fancy yourself as quite cool. Not that you would have used that expression. You wear a more colorful shirt. You sweep your hair up in a quiff. You wear kind of tapered trousers. You have kind of black boots. And these are the Teddy Boys. So what the press describe as gay dog clothes.
随着配给制的结束，随着周围有了一点钱，正在努力让自己看起来更时髦一点。所以一件时髦的领子或一件漂亮的背心或更窄的裤子之类的。然后基本上似乎发生的事情是它渗透下来了。假设你21岁，你认为自己很酷。并不是说你会用那个表达。你穿一件更鲜艳的衬衫。你把头发梳成飞机头（quiff）。你穿那种锥形裤。你穿那种黑靴子。这些就是泰迪男孩。所以媒体称之为“时髦狗衣服”（gay dog clothes）。
Gay dog clothes. Exactly. Yeah, so there's a description in a book called Hurry On Down, which was written in 1953 by a friend of Kingsley Amos called John Wayne. And he's talking about knots of youth. But not John Wayne as in the cowboy. Not the cowboy. And he says most of them wore blue or brown suits and shoes with pointed toes.
时髦狗衣服。没错。是的，所以在一本叫《Hurry On Down》的书里有描述，那是1953年由金斯利·艾米斯的一位朋友叫约翰·韦恩（John Wain）写的。他在谈论一群年轻人。但不是那个牛仔约翰·韦恩。不是那个牛仔。他说他们大多数人穿着蓝色或棕色西装，穿着尖头鞋。
But here and there, there was one with a loud tweed jacket and flannels with broader shoes, sometimes in suede. So the use of suede is a kind of giveaway. The ones in blue or brown suits had their hair swept into shiny quiffs, stiff with grease above the forehead. The others had theirs brushed smoothly back, blah, blah, blah. There were some who had violent colored shirts on to make them look like their own conception of Americans. So they don't really look like Americans. They look like what they think. But this is interesting because, of course,
但在这里和那里，有一个穿着响亮的粗花呢夹克和法兰绒裤子，穿着更宽的鞋子，有时是麂皮的。所以麂皮的使用是一种泄密。穿蓝色或棕色西装的人把头发梳成闪亮的飞机头，在额头上方用发油抹得僵硬。其他人把头发梳得平滑向后，等等等等。有些人穿着颜色强烈的衬衫，让他们看起来像他们自己心目中的美国人。所以他们看起来并不真正像美国人。他们看起来像他们认为的样子。但这很有趣，因为当然，
they're both looking back to Edward VII and what's seen as the dandyism. But also the idea that you wear something colourful makes you look American is a reminder of how far America is ahead of Britain at this point in the late 40s, early 50s. Because the grease in the hair, that's the DA, isn't it? The duck's arse, which John Travolta wears in Greece.
他们都在回顾爱德华七世和被视为花花公子风格的东西。但认为你穿鲜艳的东西会让你看起来像美国人，也提醒了人们在40年代末、50年代初，美国在这一点上领先英国有多远。因为头发里的发油，那是DA，不是吗？鸭屁股头（duck's arse），约翰·特拉沃尔塔在《油脂》（Grease）里留的那种。
Exactly. That is very American. And this is probably the first time since maybe the 20s where fashion has been shocking. So people are writing all kinds of letters to newspapers and they say, how have they got all this money? How have these young people got all this money to spend on clothes? And of course, that becomes a refrain that you hear again and again through the 50s and 60s, that they've got more money than sense and all this sort of stuff. But that dies, I would say, the Teddy Boy look, maybe 1955 or so. It's not really cool. You still see them around as you do with all these subcultures, but basically it's no longer the cutting edge. And it's been replaced by something that lots
没错。那非常美国化。这可能是自20年代以来时尚第一次令人震惊。所以人们给报纸写各种各样的信，他们说，他们哪来这么多钱？这些年轻人哪来这么多钱花在衣服上？当然，这成为了你在50年代和60年代一遍又一遍听到的副歌，他们有钱没处花之类的。但我会说，泰迪男孩的造型在1955年左右就消失了。它不再真正酷了。你仍然会像所有这些亚文化一样看到他们，但基本上它不再是前沿了。它已经被很多
of our British listeners certainly will know, which is mod, modernism. Again, there's a novel that captures this very well, a book called Absolute Beginners by Colin McGuinness. And he describes what a teenage boy looks like. This is 1959. College boy crop hair with burned in parting neat white italian rounded collared shirt short roman jacket very tailored two little vents three buttons no turn up narrow trousers 17 inch bottoms absolute maximum pointed toe shoes and a white mac lying folded by his side right so that dominic is introducing a third polar fashion which is italy yes we've had paris we've had america and now we've got italy as well yeah italy is very cool in mid to late 50s britain so this is the age of what people rather touchingly at the time
我们的英国听众肯定会知道的东西所取代，那就是摩德族（mod），现代主义。同样，有一本小说很好地捕捉到了这一点，一本叫《绝对初学者》（Absolute Beginners）的书，作者是科林·麦金尼斯（Colin MacInnes）。他描述了一个十几岁男孩的样子。这是1959年。学院派短发，中间分缝，整洁的白色意大利圆领衬衫，短罗马夹克，非常合身，两个小开叉，三个纽扣，没有翻边，窄裤子，17英寸裤脚，绝对最大，尖头鞋，旁边放着一件白色雨衣，对吧？所以多米尼克，那是引入了时尚的第三极，意大利。是的，我们有了巴黎，我们有了美国，现在我们也有了意大利。是的，意大利在50年代中后期的英国非常酷。所以这是人们当时相当感人地
called espresso bars where you would go and you would order your espresso coffee and there'd be the kind of clanking gadget machine i mean there's actually an argument among coffee bar historians i think about which was the first coffee shop to have a gadget espresso machine in mid-50s britain and these are seen as very cutting edge extraordinarily fashionable i mean so cutting edge so space age and people will dress in what they think of as Italian clothes. They wear kind of a lot of black, a lot of very tight jackets, tight trousers. Boys, of course, will often want to ride Vespa or Lambretta scooters. Because they're Italian.
称为“浓缩咖啡吧”（espresso bars）的时代，你会去那里，你会点你的浓缩咖啡，会有那种叮当作响的小玩意机器，我的意思是，关于50年代中期英国哪家咖啡店是第一家拥有小玩意浓缩咖啡机的，咖啡吧历史学家之间实际上有争论，这些被视为非常前沿，极其时尚，我的意思是，如此前沿，如此太空时代，人们会穿他们认为是意大利服装的衣服。他们穿很多黑色，很多非常紧的夹克，紧身裤。男孩们，当然，通常会想骑Vespa或Lambretta踏板车。因为它们是意大利的。
Because they're Italian. The scooter is very, very... You're looking like you're scooting around Naples or Rome. Yeah. So it's funny how in 1947, nobody had a scooter. In 1967, if you'd had a scooter, it would have been really old hat and really passe. But in 1957, the scooter is where it's at.
因为它们是意大利的。踏板车非常，非常……你看上去就像在拿坡里或罗马周围骑行。是的。所以很有趣，1947年，没人有踏板车。1967年，如果你有一辆踏板车，那将是非常老套和过时的。但在1957年，踏板车就是潮流所在。
And you're riding around in great gang on your scooters and turning up at places like Brighton where you are having run-ins with rockers. Isn't that right? Or is that not true? That is right. That does happen. But the point at which that happens, so for our overseas listeners, this is a very famous sort of fracture point in British youth culture in 1964-65. But at
你骑着踏板车成群结队地到处跑，出现在像布莱顿这样的地方，在那里你与摇滚客发生了冲突。不是吗？还是那不是真的？那是真的。那确实发生了。但发生这种情况的时间点，所以对于我们的海外听众，这是1964-65年英国青年文化中一个非常著名的断裂点。但在
the point at which that happens, it's actually long after mod has really ceased to be very fashionable. So that modernist look, you listen to jazz, you go to a cafe, you wear very tight, dark clothes. There's a sort of sense of tremendous precision about your appearance with the mods. And their enemies, as you said, the rockers who wear black leather jackets, they wear white t-shirts, they wear jeans. So again, they're looking like John Travolta in Greece. Yeah. So it's an American look. Or James Dean. Or James Dean, yeah. Well, of course, yes, because John Travolta in Greece is ersatz. Yeah.
发生这种情况的时间点，实际上是在摩德族真正不再非常时尚很久之后。所以那种现代主义造型，你听爵士乐，你去咖啡馆，你穿非常紧、深色的衣服。摩德族对你的外表有一种极大的精确感。而他们的敌人，正如你所说，穿着黑色皮夹克的摇滚客，他们穿白色T恤，穿牛仔裤。所以同样，他们看起来像《油脂》里的约翰·特拉沃尔塔。是的。所以这是一种美国造型。或者詹姆斯·迪恩（James Dean）。或者詹姆斯·迪恩，是的。嗯，当然，是的，因为《油脂》里的约翰·特拉沃尔塔是仿制品。是的。
James Dean is the original. So James Dean or Marlon Brando, I would have said, would be the two sort of obvious heroes to people. If you're genuinely cool, you don't wear either of these uniforms at this point. What do you wear if you're genuinely cool? In the mid-60s. No, no, no, in the 50s. Oh, in the 50s.
詹姆斯·迪恩是原创。所以詹姆斯·迪恩或马龙·白兰度（Marlon Brando），我会说是这两个对人们来说显而易见的英雄。如果你真的酷，你在这个时候不会穿这两种制服中的任何一种。如果你真的酷，你穿什么？在60年代中期。不，不，不，在50年代。哦，在50年代。
But in the 50s, you would wear this. You would wear this. Okay. So these are genuinely the cutting edge. They are at that point. This is like eight years before they fight each other on the beaches. But isn't there a sense, a slight sense that mods are cooler than rockers? I think there's always been that sense. But maybe that's a middle-class perspective.
但在50年代，你会穿这个。你会穿这个。好吧。所以这些确实是前沿。它们在那个时候。这就像他们在海滩上打架前八年。但难道没有一种感觉，一种轻微的感觉，摩德族比摇滚客更酷吗？我认为一直有那种感觉。但也许那是中产阶级的视角。
Mods are much more popular. I mean, mods listen to jazz. Later on, they'll listen to soul. Whereas rockers listen to kind of late fifties rock and roll. So it's kind of slight Remainers against Brexiteers vibe. A little bit. I was just thinking about that, Tom, whether you would, I knew you were going to go. Sorry, I'm so predictable. No, no, no. Because I think it's a good line because it's actually not so much class. It's about culture. Yeah. It's about the vibe.
摩德族更受欢迎。我的意思是，摩德族听爵士乐。后来，他们会听灵魂乐。而摇滚客听50年代末的摇滚乐。所以这有点像留欧派（Remainers）对抗脱欧派（Brexiteers）的氛围。有一点。我刚才就在想那个，汤姆，你是否会，我知道你要去哪里。抱歉，我太可预测了。不，不，不。因为我认为这是一句好台词，因为它实际上不是阶级问题。这是关于文化。是的。这是关于氛围。
Exactly. Do you look to America and biker films and James Dean? And is that your inspiration? Or is your inspiration coffee shops? Coffee shops and scooters. And, you know, yeah. So the mods later on will go on to be people who take loads of amphetamines and dance all night and all that stuff. But I think in the late 50s, that's not quite the case. It's two incarnations of mod, I would say.
没错。你是否看向美国和摩托车电影以及詹姆斯·迪恩？那是你的灵感吗？还是你的灵感是咖啡店？咖啡店和踏板车。而且，你知道，是的。所以摩德族后来会成为那些服用大量安非他命并整夜跳舞等等的人。但我认为在50年代末，情况并非完全如此。我会说这是摩德族的两个化身。
Late 50s and early 60s. But there's a sort of attention to detail with your clothes that would have been unthinkable in the late 1940s when you just don't have that money. You see, what's changed now is that there is so much more money around. The economy is booming. Teenagers have weekend jobs. So all these people, how do they pay for it? Some of them have pocket money, but lots of them work in hairdressers, in pubs and cafes,
50年代末和60年代初。但你对衣服的关注程度在40年代末是不可想象的，当时你根本没有那么多钱。你看，现在改变的是周围有更多的钱。经济正在繁荣。青少年有周末工作。所以所有这些人，他们怎么付钱？他们中的一些人有零花钱，但他们中的很多人在理发店、酒吧和咖啡馆工作，
after school, all of that sort of stuff. In a way, again, that would have been very, very difficult 10 or 20 years earlier. Just before we go to the break, two questions. One specifically about this very close attention to the detail of clothes among certain groups of men. This is an unbelievably homophobic age. Homosexuality is illegal. There's a deep suspicion of men who take too great an interest in fashion. Is that an issue? Is there a kind of anxieties about homosexuality around the interest
放学后，所有这些事情。以一种方式，再次，这在10或20年前会非常非常困难。在我们去休息之前，两个问题。一个专门关于某些男性群体对服装细节的这种极其密切的关注。这是一个令人难以置信的恐同时代。同性恋是非法的。人们对那些对时尚表现出太大兴趣的男性有深深的怀疑。这是一个问题吗？周围是否有关于同性恋的焦虑
in fashion in Britain? That's a really good question, Tom. And I would say probably not, actually. I think it's easy to overhype that. I think there is absolute anxiety in the newspapers about the amount of money that young people spend on clothes and about how much they care about clothes. And you see that again and again. People will write columns and letters saying, our youngsters have lost their moral bearings. They're spending all this money on clothing. They care about clothes. No one cared in my day, which is obviously untrue. This is a sign of decadence, but I think it's going slightly too far to say, therefore, it's effeminacy. Okay. And the second question, which I think is such a big question that we'll leave it to the
在英国对时尚的兴趣中？这是一个非常好的问题，汤姆。我会说可能不是，实际上。我认为夸大这一点很容易。我认为报纸上绝对有关于年轻人花在衣服上的钱的数量以及他们对衣服的关心程度的焦虑。你一遍又一遍地看到这一点。人们会写专栏和信件说，我们的年轻人失去了道德方向。他们把所有这些钱花在衣服上。他们关心衣服。在我那个时代没人关心，这显然是不真实的。这是颓废的标志，但我认为说因此它是女性化有点过分了。好吧。第二个问题，我认为这是一个如此大的问题，我们将把它留给
second half, is we've talked about boys. What about girls? So when we come back, second half, let's look at the evolution of female fashion through the 50s and into the 60s. We'll see you in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
下半场，是我们谈到了男孩。那女孩呢？所以当我们回来时，下半场，让我们看看50年代到60年代女性时尚的演变。几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history and we are looking at the evolution of london most improbably in the light of the austerity of the 1940s and the post-war years, into the leading light of global fashion in the mid-60s. And Dominic, I guess that if people think of a single item of clothing that sums up the image of Swinging London, it would be the miniskirt.
在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。前往现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们正在审视伦敦的演变，在40年代的紧缩政策和战后岁月的背景下，最不可思议地成为60年代中期全球时尚的领头羊。多米尼克，我想如果人们想到一件总结摇摆伦敦（Swinging London）形象的服装，那将是迷你裙。
Yes. How far are we from the miniskirt in the 50s? We're quite a way. We talked before the break about the new look. I mean, those are quite long, voluptuous, voluminous clothes. So teenage girls drive so much of this market. There are, I think, at the end of the 1950s, early 1960s, teenagers are spending 800 million pounds a year in Britain. And so that's economically really significant, isn't it? Really significant. And the bulk of that is driven by girls. We're going to get into later on in this half of the episode, the kind of magazines, the advertising, the way in which people are basically trying to separate teenage girls from their
是的。我们在50年代离迷你裙有多远？我们还有很长的路要走。我们在休息前谈到了新风貌。我的意思是，那些是相当长、丰满、体积庞大的衣服。所以十几岁的女孩推动了很大一部分市场。我认为在50年代末、60年代初，青少年在英国每年花费8亿英镑。所以这在经济上真的很重要，不是吗？真的很重要。其中大部分是由女孩推动的。我们将在本集下半部分的后面部分谈到，那种杂志、广告，人们基本上试图把十几岁的女孩和她们的
money and succeeding. But yeah, the miniskirt is still a few years away. Now, the person who's always credited with inventing it, no one person invented the miniskirt, by the way, but the person who's always credited with inventing it, no one person invented the miniskirt, by the way, but the person who's always credited with inventing it is probably the single most famous British designer of this period. The designer who's actually equated more than anybody else worldwide with the spirit of 60s fashion. And that is, of course, Mary Quant, Tom.
钱分开，并且成功了。但是的，迷你裙还有几年时间。现在，一直被归功于发明它的人，顺便说一句，没有人发明了迷你裙，但一直被归功于发明它的人，顺便说一句，没有人发明了迷你裙，但一直被归功于发明它的人，可能是这个时期最著名的英国设计师。这位设计师实际上比世界上任何人都更等同于60年代时尚的精神。那当然是玛丽·匡特（Mary Quant），汤姆。
I mean, even you've heard of Mary Quant. What do you mean, even me? 60s fashion is not really your... I love 60s fashion. You do, actually. I'm being very harsh. Because I've read your books. I know you are. I am being very harsh because i've read your books i know you're i'm being very harsh you are so mary quant she's almost a cliche um like all cliches with we love a cliche on the rest of this with a grain of
我的意思是，连你都听说过玛丽·昆特。你什么意思，连我？60年代的时尚并不是你的……我喜欢60年代的时尚。你确实喜欢。我刚才说得太刻薄了。因为我读过你的书。我知道你是。我刚才说得太刻薄了，因为我读过你的书，我知道你是，我刚才说得太刻薄了，你真是，所以玛丽·昆特，她几乎成了一个陈词滥调，嗯，就像所有的陈词滥调一样，我们在这档节目里喜欢陈词滥调，但要带着
truth so she is the daughter of liberal school teachers from wales she was born in 1934 she comes to study fashion at goldsmiths in london in the early 1950s she meets a guy there called alexander plunkett green who's very posh no yeah surely not with a name like that well there's a lot of very posh people in the story of 60s fashion actually or people trying to be posh through her husband so they get married through him she gets into this set who are kind of they're young they're rich they're public school educated. So for overseas listeners, confusingly, that means they're privately educated.
一点真相，所以她是来自威尔士的自由派教师的女儿，她出生于1934年，她在50年代初来到伦敦的金史密斯学院学习时装，她在那里遇到了一个叫亚历山大·普伦基特·格林的人，他非常时髦，不，肯定不是，名字听起来就不像，好吧，其实在60年代时尚的故事里有很多非常时髦的人，或者说通过她丈夫试图变得时髦的人，所以他们结婚了，通过他，她进入了这个圈子，他们有点年轻，富有，受过公立学校教育。所以对于海外听众来说，令人困惑的是，这意味着他们受过私立教育。
They are very well connected and they call themselves the Chelsea set. They live in Chelsea and Chelsea, which is West London, just west of the centre for those people who don't know London. Chelsea in the 1950s has this image, this sort of bohemian image. The best way I can give you a sort of sense of that is that in Kingsley Amis' novel, Lucky Jim, which is the story of a guy who, the classic kind of jazz listening, tweed jacket wearing young man, who's planning to escape from his academic job, Tom, and to move to the capital. Very, very commendable behavior. He is fantasizing in his
他们人脉很广，自称为“切尔西一族”。他们住在切尔西，切尔西位于伦敦西部，对于那些不了解伦敦的人来说，就在市中心以西。50年代的切尔西有这种形象，这种波西米亚式的形象。我能给你们一种感觉的最好方式是，在金斯利·艾米斯的小说《幸运的吉姆》中，这是一个关于一个人的故事，那个经典的听爵士乐、穿粗花呢夹克、计划逃离学术工作并搬到首都的年轻人，汤姆。非常、非常值得称赞的行为。他在脑海中幻想
mind about all the exciting places he could live in London. And there's a huge list of London neighborhoods as Jim is thinking a sort of stream of consciousness. And then he mentions Chelsea, and then he stops and he says, no, not Chelsea. Because Kingsley Amos hates bohemianism and he hates kind of upper-class dandies and free thinkers and people like that. And Chelsea, even at this point, early 1950s is equated with that. And the high street in Chelsea is King's Road. It's the King's Road, exactly.
着他可以住在伦敦所有令人兴奋的地方。吉姆在进行某种意识流思考时，列出了一长串伦敦街区。然后他提到了切尔西，接着他停下来，说，不，不是切尔西。因为金斯利·艾米斯讨厌波西米亚主义，他讨厌那种上流社会的纨绔子弟、自由思想家和类似的人。而切尔西，即使在那个时候，50年代初，也被等同于那种形象。切尔西的主干道是国王路。正是国王路。
And the King's Road, I guess with Carnaby Street and Soho will become one of the beating hearts of fashion. Absolutely. But at this point, actually, the King's Road, which even now, by the way, you go to the King's Road in London
我想国王路和卡纳比街以及苏豪区将成为时尚跳动的心脏之一。绝对是。但此时此刻，其实，国王路，顺便说一句，即使是现在，你去伦敦的国王路
and there will be young Japanese women walking down the King's Road looking for boutiques. It's kind of Vivienne Westwood and Malcolm McLaren as well in due course. Of course,
也会看到年轻的日本女性走在国王路上寻找精品店。到适当的时候，这里也会有薇薇安·韦斯特伍德和马尔科姆·麦克拉伦。当然，
punk later on in the 1970s. But at this point, actually, the King's Road is just a high street. So there are bakeries and there are fishmongers
后来70年代的朋克。但此时此刻，其实，国王路只是一条商业街。所以那里有面包店，有鱼贩，
and actually, in the surrounding flats, there are lots of writers and would-be writers and artists. It's not a fashionable street at all, but it's there partly because the rents are not prohibitively high. That Mary Quant, who has studied fashion at Goldsmiths, she opens a shop called Bazaar. As she says at the time, she wants it to be a wheeler base of clothes and accessories, sweaters, scarves, shifts, hats, jewelry, and peculiar odds and ends. So this is on the King's Road. This is on the King's Road.
而且实际上，在周围的公寓里，有很多作家、想成为作家的人和艺术家。它根本不是一条时尚的街道，但它之所以存在，部分原因是租金并不高得离谱。玛丽·昆特在金史密斯学院学习过时装，她开了一家叫“集市”的店。正如她当时所说，她希望它成为一个服装和配饰的集散地，毛衣、围巾、直筒裙、帽子、珠宝和奇奇怪怪的小玩意儿。所以这是在国王路上。这是在国王路上。
And this is not new look fashion. So this is not the kind of swirling, voluptuous, curvaceous, voluminous look that has been seen as the sort of cutting edge since 1947. These are very brightly colored clothes. And the key thing about it, and this will come up again and again through this story, the inspiration, she says, is children's clothes. And this is such a key element, I think, to the 60s. And actually, funnily enough, when I first wrote about this, which was 20 years ago, it didn't strike me as powerfully as it does today how odd that is and also when it starts to get a sexual dimension which we will come to how slightly unsettling that is actually to a 21st century reader i think in what sense are they drawing i mean what kind of famous five outfits yeah so pinafores the skirts are getting shorter you
而且这不是“新风貌”时尚。所以这不是那种自1947年以来被视为前沿的、旋转的、肉感的、曲线美的、宽大的风格。这些是颜色非常鲜艳的衣服。关键在于，而且这一点在这个故事中会反复出现，她说，灵感来自童装。我认为这是60年代的一个关键要素。而且说实话，当我20年前第一次写到这一点时，它并没有像今天这样强烈地打动我，意识到这有多奇怪，而且当它开始具有性维度时，我们稍后会谈到，对于21世纪的读者来说，这实际上有点令人不安，我认为，他们是在什么意义上借鉴的，我是说，什么样的“著名五人组”服装？是的，所以围裙裙，裙子变得越来越短，你
asked about getting to the mini skirts and is is that because young girls, their skirts tend to be shorter? Well, traditionally, if you're at school, if you are six years old, you're not going to be wearing a full length dress, are you? Right. I mean, you would wear a shorter skirt. And so shorter skirts for adult women make them look- It infantilizes them a bit. It infantilizes them a little bit.
问到关于迷你裙的问题，这是因为年轻女孩的裙子往往更短吗？嗯，传统上，如果你在学校，如果你六岁，你不会穿长裙，对吧？对。我的意思是，你会穿短裙。所以成年女性穿短裙让她们看起来——这有点让她们幼稚化了。这确实让她们有点幼稚化了。
So knickerbockers she has. She has kind of knee socks. The patterns that Mary Quant uses, so polka dots, stripes. Yeah, of course. I'd never thought of that. Again, they are equated with children's clothes. Even the fabrics, Tom. Gingham, most obviously, or tartan. Those are things that, you know, they are seen as the fashions.
所以她有灯笼裤。她有那种及膝袜。玛丽·昆特使用的图案，比如波点、条纹。是的，当然。我从来没想过这一点。同样，它们被等同于童装。即使是面料，汤姆。格子布，最明显的是，或者格子呢。那些是你知道的，它们被视为时尚的东西。
Oh, you mentioned the Enid Blyton famous. What kind of school uniform? Their school uniform. They're the things that Enid Blyton's kids would wear in the stories. They're jolly, bright, informal. But again, also, it's backward looking, right? I mean, as with the Teddy Boys, as with Sergeant Pepper in due course, there's a sense of people drawing inspiration directly from a past that a previous generation had come to seem as the definition of unfashionable. And therefore, for those on the cutting edge, the highly unfashionable suddenly becomes fashionable.
哦，你提到了伊妮德·布莱顿的著名作品。什么样的校服？她们的校服。那是伊妮德·布莱顿书中的孩子们会穿的东西。它们欢快、明亮、非正式。但同样，这也是向后看，对吧？我的意思是，就像泰迪男孩一样，就像后来的《佩珀中士》一样，人们有一种直接从前一代人认为已经过时的过去中汲取灵感的意识。因此，对于那些走在最前沿的人来说，极度过时的东西突然变得时尚了。
And we're aware of that as an ongoing cycle right the way up into the present. Well, people write about that all the time now. To what extent does popular culture cannibalize itself? Have we ceased to produce anything new and we're constantly just cannibalizing the past? You could reasonably argue that even at this point effectively what they're cannibalizing is the 1920s so the flapper look yeah there is a definite continuity between the flapper look and the the sort of the 60s look so mary quant anyway she does these clothes that are seen at the time as tremendously groundbreaking now just a couple of things about this first of all she she boasts at the time and it's a very 60s boast.
我们意识到这是一个持续的循环，一直延续到今天。好吧，人们现在一直在写关于这个的话题。流行文化在多大程度上在自我蚕食？我们是否已经停止生产任何新东西，而只是不断地在蚕食过去？你可以合理地争辩说，即使在这一点上，他们实际上在蚕食的是20年代，也就是飞来波女郎的风格，是的，飞来波女郎风格和60年代风格之间确实存在明确的连续性，所以玛丽·昆特，无论如何，她做的这些衣服在当时被认为是极其开创性的，现在关于这一点有几件事，首先，她在当时吹嘘，这非常60年代。
I mean, people always make this about anything they produce in the 1960s. She says, it's classless. In our shops, you will find duchesses jostling with typists to buy the same dresses. This is not true. So I gave the example, I think in one of my books in White Heat, of a pinafore dress that she made that was in vogue in 1960, and that cost 17 guineas. And that's the equivalent of three weeks wages for a young woman who works in an office. But it's interesting that she would want to make that claim. I mean, she wouldn't have wanted to make that claim presumably a decade before, where the price is the whole point. Yeah. It's a social democratic age, I think you would say, the 1950s and 1960s.
我的意思是，人们总是对他们在1960年代生产的任何东西都这样说。她说，它是无阶级的。在我们的店里，你会发现公爵夫人和打字员挤在一起买同样的裙子。这不是真的。所以我记得在我的书《白热》中举过一个例子，她制作的一件围裙裙在1960年很流行，售价17几尼。这相当于一个在办公室工作的年轻女性三周的工资。但有趣的是她会想做出这种声明。我的意思是，她大概不会想在十年前做出这种声明，那时价格才是重点。是的。我想你会说这是一个社会民主的时代，50年代和60年代。
There's still a hint of the leftover egalitarianism from the end of World War II. It's an age of full employment, an age of the surging living standards, an age when there's a reaction against what's seen as the stuffiness and the snobbery of the old establishment. But is there also a sense that fashion that is coming from the streets has a credibility that hadn't been there before is there any sense of that i think there's a slight sense there are people challenging the old very top-down fashion house directed um look there are new vehicles i mean we'll get into boutiques in just a second just before we do that mary quant one of the things about her actually is although her initial shop is really a shop for kind of slo Square people, so quite posh people in Chelsea, she does become genuinely mass market. So there has been formed a new group called the London Fashion House Group, which organizes London Fashion Weeks and organizes tours of Paris and New York.
仍然有一丝二战结束时留下的平等主义气息。这是一个充分就业的时代，一个生活水平飙升的时代，一个反对被视为旧体制的沉闷和势利的时代。但人们是否也感觉到，来自街头的时尚具有了以前所没有的信誉？有这种感觉吗？我认为有一点感觉，有人在挑战那种非常自上而下的时装屋主导的风格，有新的载体，我的意思是，我们马上就会谈到精品店，但在我们谈到之前，玛丽·昆特，关于她的一件事其实是，虽然她最初的店确实是一家为那种斯隆广场人，也就是切尔西相当时髦的人开的店，但她确实真正进入了大众市场。所以已经成立了一个名为“伦敦时装屋集团”的新组织，它组织伦敦时装周，并组织巴黎和纽约的巡回展。
And she is always at the forefront in that. And she actually signs a deal with JCPenney. So our American listeners will know the name JCPenney. It's one of the biggest clothing chains in the United States in the 60s. And they sell her label clothes in 1,700 American branches. She's the first British designer of that generation whose clothes you can buy them in Tulsa, Oklahoma, in Los Angeles, in Chicago, wherever. You know, it's a genuine kind of global reach. And it's that sort of jolly, infantile kind of look that is novel, I think, that is unusual because it's seen as unconservative and informal and all of those things.
而她总是处于最前沿。她实际上与杰西潘尼签署了一项协议。所以我们的美国听众会知道杰西潘尼这个名字。它是60年代美国最大的服装连锁店之一。他们在1700家美国分店销售她的品牌服装。她是那个时代第一位英国设计师，你可以在塔尔萨、俄克拉荷马、洛杉矶、芝加哥等任何地方买到她的衣服。你知道，这是一种真正的全球影响力。而且正是那种欢快、幼稚的风格，我认为是新颖的，是不寻常的，因为它被视为非保守的、非正式的，以及所有这些东西。
And when you say infantile, the look isn't just kind of short skirts. It's also going back to the slightly thinner look of flappers in the 20s right yeah absolutely curves or no curves anything like that we'll sort of deconstruct that a bit later on i think because um it's a fascinating thing and it becomes even more pronounced later in the 60s when he gets twiggy the rejection of the curves of the new look and the rejection of i i mean i think just as a spoiler lots of people at the time talk about it as a rejection of motherhood, a rejection of female maturity, and a huge obsession with youth, by the way. As early as 1959, Vogue has an editorial where they say that the word young is becoming the persuasive adjective for all fashions, hairstyles, and ways of life. Now, that was just not true.
当你说是幼稚时，这种风格不仅仅是短裙。它也回到了20年代飞来波女郎那种稍微瘦削的风格，对吧？是的，绝对是，曲线或没有曲线，任何类似的东西，我想我们稍后会解构一下，因为嗯，这是一件令人着迷的事情，而且在60年代后期当他得到崔姬时变得更加明显，对“新风貌”曲线的拒绝，以及对——我的意思是，我想作为一个剧透，当时很多人谈论它是对母性的拒绝，对女性成熟的拒绝，顺便说一句，对青春的巨大痴迷。早在1959年，《Vogue》就有一篇社论，他们说“年轻”这个词正在成为所有时尚、发型和生活方式的劝说性形容词。现在，那根本不是真的。
We think of that as true now, but that really wasn't true 20 or 30 years earlier. The obvious reason being that young people didn't have very much money. So there's absolutely no point in marketing all your stuff to them. And actually what happens is because there's not much money, once you become an adult, you buy adult clothes that will hopefully, that overcoat that's worth the equivalent of a thousand pounds, you're hoping that that will last you till you're dead. Yeah. You don't want to change it every... You don't want to have to change it.
我们现在认为那是真的，但在20或30年前，那真的不是真的。显而易见的原因是年轻人没有多少钱。所以把你的所有东西都推销给他们是毫无意义的。实际上发生的情况是，因为钱不多，一旦你成年，你就会买成人的衣服，希望那件价值相当于一千英镑的大衣能穿到你死。是的。你不想每……你不想不得不更换它。
Every four weeks. But by 1959, people are talking about disposable fashion, about clothes that you will wear for just one year and then you will ditch, even when you're 19, 20. So you talked about how Marie Kwan's first boutique is actually very very expensive yeah what's the process whereby these clothes start to percolate down so the classic figure is the dolly bird yes yeah right these are the the girls who are going to you know screaming at the beatles or yeah cilla black i guess cilla Cilla Black. And nobody outside Britain will know who Cilla Black was. But Google her.
每四周。但到了1959年，人们开始谈论一次性时尚，谈论你只会穿一年然后就会扔掉的衣服，即使你才19、20岁。所以你谈到了玛丽·昆特的第一家精品店其实非常非常昂贵，是的，这些衣服开始渗透下去的过程是什么？所以经典的形象是“多莉鸟”，是的，对吧，这些是那些去尖叫着看披头士乐队的女孩，或者，我想是希拉·布莱克，希拉·布莱克。英国以外没人会知道希拉·布莱克是谁。但去谷歌搜索她。
Look her up. So the big phenomenon is the rise of the independent little boutique. Previously, you bought your clothes often from a department store or a shop like Marks and Spencer. So a high street store. Now, those department stores, even quite small, not small towns, but medium-sized towns might have a department store. These are places with long leases and high rents. Boutiques are very different. They have short-term
去查查她。所以巨大的现象是独立小精品店的兴起。以前，你通常从百货公司或像玛莎百货这样的商店买衣服。所以是商业街商店。现在，那些百货公司，即使是相当小的，不是小城镇，但中等规模的城镇可能有百货公司。这些地方租约长，租金高。精品店非常不同。它们有短期
leases and they're paying low rents. The shop is often down a side street. It's not on the main road because it's too expensive. And they're young people who open them. They may only be around for two or three years. The atmosphere is much more informal. And it's actually through those shops opening in places across Britain that the Mary Quant look is kind of diffused. And people are copying it because they've seen it in magazines and things, which again, we'll get onto. And the Dolly Bird, so we said before that the people who are really driving this are young women or young girls, women between the ages of, let's say, 13, 14, and maybe 24, 25. And they absolutely, the Mary Quant look, it's modern, it's informal, it's quite
租约，而且租金低。商店通常在小巷里。它不在主干道上，因为那里太贵了。而且是年轻人开了这些店。它们可能只存在两三年。氛围要随意得多。而且实际上正是通过这些在英国各地开设的商店，玛丽·昆特的风格才得以传播。人们在模仿它，因为他们在杂志之类的东西上看到了它，我们稍后会谈到这一点。而“多莉鸟”，所以我们之前说过，真正推动这一点的人是年轻女性或年轻女孩，年龄在，比如说，13、14岁到可能24、25岁之间的女性。而且她们绝对，玛丽·昆特的风格，它是现代的，它是非正式的，它是相当
androgynous. That definitely has begun to conquer the mass market by the early 1960s. How? I mean, how are people, say, outside London? Yeah, how do they see it? Outside the West End. How are they coming across these fashions? Magazines or TV or what?
中性的。到60年代初，这绝对已经开始征服大众市场了。怎么做到的？我的意思是，人们，比如说，伦敦以外的人？是的，他们是怎么看到的？西区以外。他们是怎么接触到这些时尚的？杂志还是电视还是什么？
TV is part of it. So by the late 1950s, both the BBC and ITV, their commercial competitor, are running weekly pop music programs, sort of Ready, Steady, Go, Six Five Special. These kind of programs in which you see pop groups Go, Six Five Special, these kinds of programs in which you see pop groups who are wearing these clothes, but you also see the audience. Of course, not everybody has a TV at this point. So even more important than TV, I would argue, are magazines. Women's magazines had always been massive. So there's a magazine called Woman. And in the late 1950s, there's some extraordinary statistic that out of all the British women between the ages of 16 and 44, half of them read Woman Magazine. Wow, that is stupefying figures.
电视是其中的一部分。所以到了50年代末，英国广播公司和独立电视台，它们的商业竞争对手，都在播放每周的流行音乐节目，比如《准备，就绪，出发》，《六五特别节目》。这些节目中你可以看到流行乐队，在这些节目中你可以看到流行乐队，他们穿着这些衣服，但你也能看到观众。当然，此时并非每个人都有电视。所以我认为，比电视更重要的是杂志。女性杂志一直都很庞大。所以有一本叫《女性》的杂志。在50年代末，有一个惊人的统计数据，在所有16到44岁的英国女性中，有一半人阅读《女性》杂志。哇，这真是令人震惊的数字。
But also the new thing is magazines for teenage girls, for very young women. And they obviously didn't really exist before because they didn't have the money. Now there are magazines like Romeo, Mirabelle, Boyfriend. The most famous one is called Honey. Honey was launched in 1960, circulation 140,000. Their slogan, I mean, you're talking about the Teddy Boys as gay dog clothes. Their slogan is young, gay, and going far. And they sponsor boutiques, they sponsor hairdressers, they organize tours.
但新的东西也是针对少女、非常年轻的女性的杂志。它们显然在之前并不真正存在，因为她们没有钱。现在有了像《罗密欧》、《米拉贝尔》、《男朋友》这样的杂志。最著名的一本叫《蜂蜜》。《蜂蜜》于1960年创刊，发行量14万。他们的口号，我的意思是，你在谈论泰迪男孩作为“同性恋狗”服装。他们的口号是“年轻、快乐、前途无量”。他们赞助精品店，赞助理发师，组织巡回演出。
And it's all, you know, you will attract the right boy. You will be economically successful. You will get a good job. You will do all this if you wear the right clothes and you have the right makeup. So those magazines
而且这一切，你知道，你会吸引到合适的男孩。你会经济上成功。你会找到一份好工作。如果你穿合适的衣服，化合适的妆，你就会做到这一切。所以那些杂志
are kind of working cahoots in a way, as they do today, as, you know, Instagram influencers do today with the fashion industry. Right. And so Instagram influencers depend on photography. What about the fashion magazines?
在某种程度上是狼狈为奸的，就像今天一样，就像，你知道，Instagram网红今天与时尚产业所做的那样。对。所以Instagram网红依赖摄影。那时尚杂志呢？
Because fashion photographers become part of Swinging London as well, don't they? Photography is absolutely massive in this period. The magazine that really pioneers this is a completely different magazine called The Queen and later rebranded Queen. So it was bought by a guy called Jocelyn Stevens, who's a young man. He becomes the head of English Heritage. Yeah, exactly. There you go, Tom.
因为时尚摄影师也成为了“摇摆伦敦”的一部分，不是吗？摄影在这个时期绝对是巨大的。真正开创这一先河的杂志是一本完全不同的杂志，叫《女王》，后来更名为《女王》。所以它被一个叫乔斯林·史蒂文斯的人买下了，他是个年轻人。他后来成为了英格兰遗产委员会的负责人。是的，没错。就是这样，汤姆。
Very improbably. What an unexpected link that is. Very sound views on Stonehenge. Oh, excellent. Excellent views. Wow, I did not see that coming. So he bought, when he was 25, he bought this dusty society magazine called The Queen,
非常不可思议。这是一个多么意想不到的联系。对巨石阵有非常合理的看法。哦，太棒了。极好的观点。哇，我没预料到这一点。所以他在25岁时买下了这本尘封的社会杂志《女王》，
and he says, I'm going to make this the magazine for the new generation. And he recruits a very famous photographer, Anthony Armstrong Jones, who becomes Lord Snowden, marries Princess Margaret. Yeah, familiar to viewers of The Queen. Very familiar to viewers of The Queen. Sorry, The Crown. Sorry.
他说，我要把它做成新一代的杂志。他招募了一位非常有名的摄影师，安东尼·阿姆斯特朗-琼斯，他后来成为了斯诺登伯爵，娶了玛格丽特公主。是的，《王冠》的观众很熟悉。非常熟悉《王冠》的观众。抱歉，《王冠》。抱歉。
All these queens and crowns. So it's probably The Queen magazine that inspires the most famous magazines of all, which are the colour supplements. Most people listening to this will be like, what? I can't believe they're claiming that colour supplements and newspapers are something incredibly exciting and radical. But they are, Tom. So when the Sunday Times launches its colour section in February 1962, this is one of the landmark publications of Britain in the 1960s. Well, I mean, any massive stars appear in the Sunday Times colour supplement.
所有的这些女王和王冠。所以很可能是《女王》杂志激发了最著名的杂志，也就是彩色增刊。大多数听众会想，什么？我不敢相信他们声称报纸的彩色增刊是极其令人兴奋和激进的东西。但它们确实是，汤姆。所以当《星期日泰晤士报》在1962年2月推出其彩色版时，这是英国60年代的里程碑式出版物之一。好吧，我的意思是，任何大明星都会出现在《星期日泰晤士报》的彩色增刊上。
That is absolutely true. I hadn't thought of that god how low have they fallen tom that their very first edition was a photograph of the supermodel of the age gene shrimpton modeling a mary quant dress photographed by the great photographer of the age david bailey the headline says there's going to be a story by i Fleming, a new James Bond story. And of course, the most recent iteration of the Sunday Times magazine, Tom featured, the rest is history. So that tells you. Hot models sporting the very latest in overcoat
那是绝对正确的。我没想到这一点，天哪，他们堕落到什么地步了，汤姆，他们的第一版就是那个时代的超模简·施林普顿穿着玛丽·昆特裙子的照片，由那个时代伟大的摄影师大卫·贝利拍摄。标题说会有一个故事，由伊恩·弗莱明撰写，一个新的詹姆斯·邦德故事。当然，最近一次迭代的《星期日泰晤士报》杂志，汤姆，特色内容，剩下的就是历史了。所以这告诉你了。穿着最新大衣的火辣模特
fashion. Yes. I should just intrude at this point because Theo, who is 13, has no idea what a colour supplement is. I know. This is the one podcast Tom, we've done that makes me feel really old because this is all just babble to theo just completely incomprehensible babble so color supplement it's a magazine that's in color that comes with the newspaper and of course people didn't do that before it was much more difficult
时尚。是的。我应该在这一点上插一句，因为13岁的西奥根本不知道什么是彩色增刊。我知道。这是我们做过的唯一一期让汤姆觉得我真的很老的播客，因为这对西奥来说完全是胡言乱语，完全无法理解的胡言乱语。所以彩色增刊，它是一本随报纸附送的彩色杂志，当然人们以前不这样做，因为这要困难得多
to do because color printing was so expensive, rather like colorful clothes. These things are only possible because of the technological advances. And it's very 60s, isn't it? Again, bright primary colors. So the other newspapers like the Observer and the Sunday Telegraph, Russia Follows Suit, they make stars of the photographers. So the three in particular, very famous to people who remember the 1960s, Terence Donovan, Brian Duffy, and most famously of all, David Bailey. David Bailey is from the East End of London. He was born in 1938. He fell in love with photography during his national service. So for those people who don't know, that means you were conscripted effectively and you went and served overseas in the 1950s in the colonies, in the British Army. He was sent to Singapore. He fell in love with photography there.
做到，因为彩色印刷太贵了，就像色彩鲜艳的衣服一样。这些事情只有在技术进步的情况下才有可能。而且这非常60年代，不是吗？同样，明亮的基色。所以其他报纸，如《观察家报》和《星期日电讯报》，俄罗斯紧随其后，他们让摄影师成为了明星。所以特别是这三位，对于记得60年代的人来说非常有名，特伦斯·多诺万、布莱恩·达菲，以及最著名的戴维·贝利。戴维·贝利来自伦敦东区。他出生于1938年。他在国民服役期间爱上了摄影。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，这意味着你实际上被征召入伍，你在50年代在殖民地，在英国军队中服役。他被派往新加坡。他在那里爱上了摄影。
He'd always been interested in birdwatching, ironically. Birdwatching. Thanks for that. That was a lovely one. That's a very authentic 60s joke. It is. It's a very 60s joke. And people like David Bailey, who have risen from working class backgrounds through their talent. I mean, there's no one can question these people are immensely
他一直对观鸟感兴趣，讽刺的是。观鸟。谢谢你。那是一个可爱的笑话。这是一个非常地道的60年代笑话。确实。这是一个非常60年代的笑话。像戴维·贝利这样的人，通过他们的才华从工人阶级背景中崛起。我的意思是，没有人能质疑这些人是极其
talented. They have an amazing eye and they're shooting very sort of kinetic informal pictures there's a very a great break with the sort of stylized 1940s 1950s very stiff and stuffy fashion photographs they become kind of folk heroes actually so you mentioned austin powers yeah at the beginning austin powers is a photographer of course he is i've forgotten and there's no other age actually yeah i mean we have my friend chris floyd who is a photographer who's photographed some incredible people, listens to this podcast, is a member of the Rest Is History Club. But, I mean, even he would, I'm sure, admit that photographers in the 21st century are not the folk heroes that they were in the 1960s,
有才华的。他们有惊人的眼光，他们拍摄的是非常动感的、非正式的照片，这与那种程式化的40年代、50年代非常僵硬和沉闷的时尚照片有很大的决裂。他们实际上成为了某种民间英雄。所以你提到了奥斯汀·鲍尔斯，是的，在开头，奥斯汀·鲍尔斯当然是一位摄影师，我忘了。而且其实没有其他时代了，是的，我的意思是，我的朋友克里斯·弗洛伊德，他是一位拍摄过一些不可思议的人的摄影师，听这个播客，是“历史就是一切”俱乐部的成员。但是，我的意思是，即使是他，我相信也会承认，21世纪的摄影师不是60年代那样的民间英雄，
when, thanks partly to Lord Snowden, Anthony Armstrong Jones, they are, I mean, when David Bailey gets divorced, that news is on the front page of the newspapers. He's a star. It's a big, big deal. So Dominic, photographers are very groovy, but equally groovy are the people that they're shooting. I love the fact that you're now doing this as Austin Powers. Better believe it, baby. So you mentioned Jean Shrimpton appearing in the first edition of the Sunday Times Colour Supplement. And she's probably the most famous model of the 60s?
当时，部分归功于斯诺登伯爵，安东尼·阿姆斯特朗-琼斯，他们是，我的意思是，当戴维·贝利离婚时，那个新闻就在报纸的头版。他是个明星。这是一件非常非常大的事。所以多米尼克，摄影师非常时髦，但同样时髦的是他们拍摄的人。我喜欢你现在像奥斯汀·鲍尔斯一样做这件事的事实。最好相信它，宝贝。所以你提到了简·施林普顿出现在《星期日泰晤士报》彩色增刊的第一版中。她是60年代最著名的模特吗？
Definitely. So just tell us about her. So she comes from the edge of the county set, I suppose you would say the gentry, in Buckinghamshire. Her father was a businessman. He worked in the building trade. She's tall and immensely, obviously, incredibly good looking. She was going to become a secretary, but she ends up signing on at the Lucy Clayton Modelling School, which is the modelling school in London.
绝对是。所以给我们讲讲她。所以她来自郡县阶层的边缘，我想你会说是乡绅，在白金汉郡。她父亲是个商人。他在建筑行业工作。她很高，而且显然，非常非常漂亮。她本来要成为一名秘书，但她最终在露西·克莱顿模特学校注册，那是伦敦的模特学校。
And she is shooting an advert for Corn Flakes when David Bailey spots her. And he books her to do a shoot for vogue and they basically not just become i mean it's very common with these photographers they would have a single muse that they worked with all the time that they would end up having a relationship with which is exactly what happens with david bailey and gene shrimpton and they command enormous amounts of kind of newspaper attention in the early 60s. And the thing about her is that she's seen as quite girl next door. So she's incredibly good looking, but she's sort of tall and lissom and kind of willowy.
她正在拍摄一个玉米片的广告，这时戴维·贝利发现了她。他预订她为《Vogue》拍摄，他们基本上不仅成为——我的意思是，这在这些摄影师中非常普遍，他们会有一个他们一直合作的单一缪斯，他们最终会建立一段关系，这正是戴维·贝利和简·施林普顿发生的事情，他们在60年代初获得了大量的报纸关注。关于她的一点是，她被视为相当邻家女孩。所以她非常漂亮，但她有点高挑、苗条，有点像柳树。
Again, she's not terribly curvaceous. Yeah. And that's, I mean, I'm not being prurient. That's an important part of her appeal. Because that's the 60s look. Because the look is not to be immensely curvaceous. The look is to be sort of, well, twig-like. Yeah, she looks younger than she is, I think it's fair to say.
同样，她不是特别有曲线。是的。而且那是，我的意思是，我不是在表现得淫秽。那是她吸引力中重要的一部分。因为那是60年代的风格。因为这种风格不是要非常有曲线。这种风格是要，嗯，像树枝一样。是的，我认为公平地说，她看起来比实际年龄要小。
And what also makes her a big star, and this is where we should end. Tom, it's great to end a fashion podcast on a cliffhanger. Yeah. So to give you some sense of what a big star she is. I mean, she has been on the cover of Vogue and Glamour and Elle and all these magazines. And she's seen in America, in Europe as by far the most famous model in the world. In the autumn of 1965, she's offered a job in Melbourne, Australia, and she's going to be modeling a range of synthetic all-on dresses at this big racing
而且让她成为大明星的还有，这就是我们应该结束的地方。汤姆，在悬念中结束时尚播客真是太棒了。是的。所以为了让你了解她有多大的明星效应。我的意思是，她上过《Vogue》、《Glamour》、《Elle》和所有这些杂志的封面。她在美洲、欧洲被视为迄今为止世界上最著名的模特。1965年秋天，她得到了一份在澳大利亚墨尔本的工作，她将在那个大型赛车比赛中展示一系列合成的all-on裙子
carnival that they have in Melbourne that includes the Derby. And to give you a sense of what a star she is, when the Beatles had gone to Australia, they had been paid 1,500 pounds. She is going to be paid 2,000 pounds by the Victoria Racing Club. And she doesn't have to split it four ways, does she? She doesn't have to split it. Yeah, exactly. That is a year's income for the average Australian. And she's just basically been told to go there for two weeks. And she arrives on Derby Day at the Flemington race course. This is the height of the kind of Melbourne season. So all the posh people in Melbourne, such as they are,
他们在墨尔本举办的嘉年华，其中包括德比大赛。为了让你了解她有多大的明星效应，当披头士乐队去澳大利亚时，他们得到了1500英镑的报酬。她将从维多利亚赛马俱乐部获得2000英镑的报酬。而且她不必分四份，对吧？她不必分。是的，没错。那是普通澳大利亚人一年的收入。而且她基本上只是被告知去那里两周。她在德比日抵达弗莱明顿赛马场。这是墨尔本赛季的高潮。所以墨尔本所有时髦的人，就他们而言，
Australia, of course, Tom, they have turned. Dominic. We're going to Australia in November. We are, but they love it though don't they I would just like Australians to know that I do not associate myself
澳大利亚，当然，汤姆，他们已经转了。多米尼克。我们十一月要去澳大利亚。我们是，但他们喜欢它，不是吗？我只是想让澳大利亚人知道，我一点也不认同
at all with that comment by Dominic she arrives on the 30th of October 1965 everybody is so excited that she is going the local
多米尼克的那个评论。她在1965年10月30日抵达，每个人都非常兴奋她要去，当地的
Melbourne Sun News Pictorial says you know we are going to be treated to the spectacle of the most beautiful girl on earth but Tom what she does that day
《墨尔本太阳新闻画报》说，你知道，我们将有幸看到地球上最美丽的女孩的奇观。但汤姆，她那天做的事
in melbourne at the racecourse not only sends shockwaves through anglo-australian relations it's a landmark in human history wow and on that bombshell can we really leave people hanging not knowing we must. The good thing is, Tom, if people are members of the Restless History Club, they can find out what she does. They can find out now. But otherwise, they'll have to wait till the next episode, which is awful
在墨尔本的赛马场，不仅在英澳关系中引起了冲击波，而且是人类历史上的一个里程碑。哇，带着这个重磅炸弹，我们真的能让人们悬着心不知道吗？我们必须。好消息是，汤姆，如果人们是“历史就是一切”俱乐部的成员，他们可以找出她做了什么。他们现在就可以找出。但否则，他们将不得不等到下一集，这太糟糕了
because we've never had a bigger cliffhanger in the Restless History. It's huge. Alright, so we will be back next time when we continue the story of 60s fashion. London really does start to swing. But before London starts to swing, Dominic will reveal what the shrimp does in Melbourne.
因为我们从未在“历史就是一切”中有过更大的悬念。这太大了。好吧，所以我们下次回来时将继续60年代时尚的故事。伦敦确实开始摇摆了。但在伦敦开始摇摆之前，多米尼克将揭示“虾”在墨尔本做了什么。
History cliffhangers. Don't get bigger than that. We'll see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
历史悬念。没有比这更大的了。我们下次见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐就是一切》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。